how does someone know that the
entertainment industry is right for them
you can do anything else I'm sure you've
had other people tell you this if
there's any other business that you can
do and be happy go do that because this
is such a tough
competitive totally rewarding but super
competitive business with lots of
rejection if you have a thick skin and
it's hard when you're an artist because
your art um my colleague Jeff melvoy in
the wga showrunner training program says
you like an M&M a Eminem P you have to
have a a hard uh candy shell but a soft
chocolate Center oh so that's the image
to think of you have to have your art
which is the soft chocolate but you have
to be able to withstand the business
which is the hard candy sh sh well there
are some people though that they thrive
on a challenge you know they get bored
easily usually because they're good at
everything and then they they just kind
of like no this is too easy and they
they Tire of it so it seems like too
that maybe someone in that headp space
would it would be good to try I don't
know maybe they would get bored of
different things well if they're bored
because they're so successful like bless
them because they're they are a unicorn
cuz that's not how it generally happens
um but if somebody is willing to take
risks if somebody is willing to
withstand rejection and get back up if
somebody has
perseverance then this is the business
for them if if they have a driving
passion to tell a story or to tell
stories or to make a difference and
through entertainment I think people can
really make a difference in the culture
in the
conversation and if you're driven to do
that and you can deal with all the other
things the ancillary things that go with
it then this is absolutely the business
for you ancillary like what
rejection
competitiveness
rejection having to get your 10,000
hours in having to become excellent at
what you are wanting to do at what
you're doing be heading shoulders above
everybody else that's what it takes to
stand
out and be easy to work with likable oh
yeah um you know do great in a room yes
that's not hard oh no that's easy um I
tell my daughter who and I didn't help
her get this job I promise you she is
the showrunner assistant on the show
never have I ever um her boss is the
showrunner on that show and she wants to
be a staff writer and I tell her and
every other young person that wants to
be a television writer you need to have
talent but Talent is not the most
important thing you have to have a
fantastic work ethic you have to have a
personality that people want to be
around that you're a pleasure you're
Pleasant to be around that work ethic is
I'll do whatever it takes and then some
you need to know people and you need to
continue to expand and grow your
community of mutually beneficial
relationships that's all the things in
your control that you have to do and
then luck and timing come into it
too wow because it seems
counterintuitive maybe that's the wrong
word but as being a writer and and
having stories and being in your head
all the time usually those come from
being away from people and actually
enjoying that they should be feature
writers they should write screenplays
for motion pictures because you get to
be by yourself when you do that but if
you have an interest in being in
television it is a collaborative
experience and you need to be able to
listen to other people's ideas add to
them not reject them and and be somebody
who's to use the word again additive and
somebody who's fun you you need to and
upbeat and doesn't take themselves too
seriously what if a writer knows they
want to write a b there's so many shows
they love to watch they want to be part
of it they want to be additive as you
said but they don't actually know what a
successful career looks like right a
successful career in order to if we're
talking about television in order to be
successful in television you need to be
able to have people who advocate for you
you can't just have your agent or
manager send your workout you need to
get
alliances and you need people to say
when you're up for a show wow I've
worked with her or he's terrific I
mentored him and you need that so you
need a temperament that goes along with
making connections hopefully genuine
connections being of help to people
and not taking yourself too
seriously how does someone deprogram
themselves from that what if they don't
realize they take themselves
seriously if they don't realize that
they take themselves seriously they're
going to run into a brick wall People
based on their talent may give them a
shot once but they won't be invited back
and so the world will give them feedback
on that or if you have a lovely generous
showrunner or upper level writer they'll
take you aside and say this is a problem
you're you're a downer and you you your
sense of self-importance is getting in
the way of you being a team player you
should only be so lucky to have somebody
like that we've all had teachers
probably in our lives that have been
wonderful and they have kind of taken
you under their wing W with good
intentions yeah and then we've also
probably all had the opposite and so if
if we're lucky to find someone that that
can maybe they see themselves in that
student or whatever and they they
genuinely want to help them there's no
alterior motive well that's a teacher or
a mentor that's not
employment and that's a difference
a mentor or a
teacher if they're very generous if
they're Savvy they'll say you are
wonderful but your attitude is going to
sink you if we're talking about an
employment situation you have one shot
if there's a I I don't know whether I
said it in my book or someplace else but
there's a life is too short list and
even if you're successful if you're
annoying or difficult
or
awful as a person uh people won't want
to be in business with you because life
is too short if you're combative if you
don't take notes they'll remember
that okay what if you're none of those
things but you you freeze up in a room
you're actually probably a good person
inside but you just you have a hard time
in a mixer you have a hard time in a
room right well the thing I recommend to
all writers is take improv
classes that will help you stay present
in the moment when you're anxious it's
because you're in your head you're not
in the moment talking to somebody you're
thinking what are they thinking about me
oh my God I'm not saying the right thing
improv is a fantastic way to do that um
another way is there's some there used
to be something called Toast Masters um
if there still is go do that learn how
to speak in front of people um I had a
client who was so anxious in the room
and I gave her the name of a therapist
who does cognitive behavioral therapy
and he helped her get past it we talked
earlier about uh being tough and you
said that there was a showrunner or
someone that you knew who said kind of
like were we have to be like M&M's I
like that analogy so hard candy shell on
the outside right and then uh nice
chocolate soft Inside Yes um Can
toughness ruin someone's writing what if
you've mastered that part but you've
also then lost yourself because now you
have this Teflon shell and the
Humanity's been pushed down so much you
have a problem the truth is you have a
problem that's good okay number one sure
and
um you need to figure
out how to get back to the thing that
got you excited about it in the first
place let's say you're a writer excited
about being a writer in the first place
and try and get back there um I think
you can ask your friends for help and
say you know what I've I've lost my
North Star here can do you have
suggestions questions on how on how I
can get it back I mean maybe you work
with a coach or something like that a
therapist and say this was great it
helped me be tough but as you said I've
lost the artist of in me and you need to
get that back maybe you go on an artist
Retreat maybe you take new classes you
you just try and get in touch with that
part of yourself again because just
being tough is is not going to do the
job for you it really is a fine line you
have to walk both of them sure then
maybe you know law or real estate's for
you right not not not uh being a a show
writer what if your friends are all yes
people and they don't want to tell you
the truth find new friends okay um you
have to have people that will tell you
the truth you really do and
it's so interesting because you want
people who will tell you the truth but
not people who are going to be
mean who they have a vested interest in
pushing you down um that's why I go back
to a therapist or a coach a coach has
nothing invested in you except your
success and they can
say this is not working you you came to
me because you're having a problem and
this is what the problem is and let's
work on how we can fix it sure well
therapists still want to get paid though
that's well so do consult so do coaches
yeah so yeah but they want to continue
the relationship that is true you know
what I hadn't thought about that I was
thinking about myself as a coach I just
want them to get better there are people
who are just in it for themselves and
they're going to string you along so try
and find somebody who has your best
interests and want you to get to where
you need to go quickly